okay next caller if from the seven six
zero area code caller from seven six
zero go ahead good morning David I just
want to say thanks for everything that
you do I think you're a strong
progressive way so this is Tyler and I'm
calling from San Diego my question is is
more related to like everybody missing
the force for all the trees here at some
point we're gonna have to have some sort
of reconciliation with this Muller
investigation either there's going to be
something that comes out of it or
something that doesn't come out of it
right and regardless of where you stand
on this somewhere between 40% and 60% of
the country is not going to accept that
outcome right and I'm just curious
should we be super concerned about the
country at this point yes we should now
here's the thing there is eventually
going to be some end to the Moller
investigation and it's ultimately not
going to come down
I don't believe to whether forty or
sixty percent of the country agree or
disagree with the outcome it's gonna be
much simpler than that it's going to
come down to who is in control of the
House and Senate at that time and it has
been made abundantly clear through the
smear campaigns against robert muller
that if it's republicans who control the
House and Senate at the time where we
finally get from Muller here's what
happened here are the charges that I
believe that crimes I believe were
committed if it's Republicans we're
simply not going to see consequences and
this is why it's important that people
vote in November but yes you're
completely right that eventually there
will be some end to this thing and Italy
it will either lead to consequences or
it will not great thank you for your
views I appreciate it
all right thank you so much for calling
in great to hear from Tyler in San Diego
love San Diego haven't been there for
years though